School library books book bands are seen
as targeting lgbtq content Iowa
Republican Governor Kim Reynolds pushes
an especially sweeping Crackdown on
content in Iowa school libraries the
bill she's backing could result in the
removal of books from schools libraries
in all of the state's 327 districts if
they're successfully challenged in any
one of them under a bill back by
Reynolds the titles and authors of all
books available to students in
classrooms and libraries must it would
be posted online and officials would
need to specify how parents could
request the book's removal and how
decisions to retain books could be
appealed when any District removes a
book the state's education department
would add it to a removal list and all
of iOS 326 school districts would have
to deny access to the book unless
parents gave approval the parents are
the governing Authority in how their
child is educated period said senator
Amy Sinclair parents are responsible for
their child's upbringing period Terry
Patrick a mother of two press a
befunnement about why anyone would want
to make sexually explicit books
available to Children what are your
thoughts on this yeah you know I like we
put in a lot of work especially here at
my home
um in Orange Unified School District we
actually were able to flip our board to
be more conservative and they actually
terminated our superintendent and are in
the process right now of replacing that
individual they did this because of a
lot of the sexual things that were
happening to Children within these books
and so our board actually had to make
drastic decisions and offloading an app
to get rid of these books and the
question really comes is all of these
parents for the last year or two that
have been complaining about these porn
style books that are available to
students why hasn't anyone with their
right mind saying that this should not
be available to students this should not
be available to five-year-olds and if
you're going to make it available to
your your students it should be at an
appropriate age but but here's with
parto I'm open to being sold if you can
logically sell it to me how are they
selling that that's normal that you
should be okay with that how are you
selling it to parents yeah so there's
these things I call it gay privilege
when you paint something as inclusivity
you plain you paint it as Pride you
paint it as love as my community you
automatically get this precedent that if
you do not go along with this then
you're homophobic or you're transphobic
and no one wants to fall under that
category based on how our society
perceives these people now you have
people like us like gays against
groomers that says oh no no no no no
this book that is showing two children
have sex this has absolutely nothing to
do with pride and inclusivity this has
everything to do with indoctrination
they associate it with book Banning now
those people you know they'll say that
people oh these are like conservatives
handbooks and that and in the meantime
if you looked back I mean would you put
Playboy magazines from back in the day
into a child School library no you
wouldn't there was some moral barometer
of what was acceptable there was a
barometer if you sent your kid into a
neighbor's house and we had a we had we
found out in our neighborhood when I was
growing up there was a guy that was a
little strange and a friend of mine
found it out because she went and baby
sat there and they were just Playboy
magazines everywhere and these were all
young and the parents said you're not
going there anymore you're not
babysitting you're not doing any of that
stuff but we had a moral barometer of
what was acceptable you have a school
library and you have kids of a certain
age bracket every book in that Library
should be pertinent for kids of that age
bracket I don't know why this has gotten
so complex and so hard and it seems to
me that what you're saying is accurate
that everyone's afraid to challenge just
this immoral stuff or this stuff that's
just not appropriate for that age group
because they're afraid of what how
they're going to be labeled then they're
going to be ostracized then you know
someone on social media is going to make
a video about them then they're going to
you know have a problem at their job
it's going to balloon and that person's
suddenly going to lose their job their
financial stability so everyone's like
let me just shut up and who's getting
hurt are the kids because then they go
into that school library and as a 14
year old reading a book that's
appropriate for a grown adult and not
for them so ultimately you have to speak
up people like you who you know run
these organizations parents have to walk
into these School libraries and say I'm
going to rip my kids out of this school
if you don't stop putting inappropriate
content in this library and if a whole
if a whole school of parents showed up
and did that they'd have to change what
are all the schools going to be empty no
it doesn't work like that you band
together and you do something about it
that that kid must have lived in a
high-end Community where the parents had
Playboy magazines
we found LA Express we couldn't afford
Playboy magazine when we were 14 15
years old but I don't know if you're
little kids though she was going to
babysit five and six years but you know
even with that the responsibility of
that is still parents screwing that up
yeah which is fine let the parents screw
it up but we knew
of course now a teacher doing that and
thinking it's appropriate to put it in a
book to say you know picture two boys
what that's the part of how are you
selling these parents for some parents
to say yes Tom do you have any thoughts
on this yeah I think it goes both ways
and I think you know yeah a lot of them
do go both ways that's a different
Community that's a bisexual
that's next Thursday go ahead I'm sorry
I thought you were already the B that's
what the b stands for there you go we're
all learning here right no I mean you
never know though unless if you time try
but go ahead you were saying I think
it's important to make to make that
point right is you know appropriateness
for all because the
you know you don't want any one
Community to say oh we're being singled
out being discriminated against well
they can claim to feel that way but
frankly for libraries we want
age-appropriate you know material all
across Spectrum you know
heterosexual homosexual all that stuff
we don't want any of that to be in front
of kids you know that's that's the point
and it's not you know Banning just gay
books or Banning just this it is
basically saying hey there's an
appropriate age for this you know you
parents for the longest time help me out
Jed because you're an administrator
could opt in or opt out of certain
videos that they would do for health for
girls sign a form in seventh grade hey
let you know next week April 11th we're
gonna do this this is the film this is
what's it about it's been used since
1985 and so parents and have a phone you
know what no I'm gonna have the
conversation with my daughter don't
she's not gonna watch that film with you
um fine and so for the longest time
there is this moral barometer and
Sensibility but it was on both ways it's
like sexualized content not going to be
in front of kids at an inappropriate age
period so nobody is singling out lgbtq
books nobody is Banning books in the
name of McCarthyism on one side of a
political line here this is kids or kids
and adults or adults and there's content
for either they sell it by the way to
parents because the same way they sold
condom distribution in schools they say
this is happening in society so we're
just showcasing what's happening in
society they also say well not every kid
has parents some kids don't have the
structure at home to explain these
things so it's our job now to stand in
and have these conversations with kids
that's outsold I just want to point out
they're going to do it anyway let's make
sure that they're doing it safely and
they use safe I just I just want to
point out these books that we're talking
about are not simply you know a dad and
a dad raising a kid taking them trigger
treating in a coloring book we're
talking about a book that is showing
kids sexual fetishes how to use sexual
objects you know having sex in these
books all cartoon is this a joke are you
being I am not joking the the speech you
saw me give in Poway Unified School
District we blew up these pictures in in
two feet by three feet and displayed
them for the school board and said these
are these are pictures you have in your
classroom books that is available to
students and when you look at these
people and they say you're homophobic
it's like this has nothing to do with
sexuality we just don't want porn in
classrooms with t with kids it's
inappropriate and they're using my this
is why when we were talking my community
the LGBT community has been hijacked so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you
foreign